stranded and a hundred miles away from
home
this minky whale which spent much of the
day caught up in the currents of the
thames
stuck and distressed has now been
euthanized
if we were just let it back in the river
it would potentially just drown
you just can't keep prolonging the life
of an animal that really has no
no chance of survival when it goes back
the young whale was malnourished
injured and weak a rescue attempt was
made in the early hours but later this
morning
the 12-bit well resurfaced in teddington
lock a few miles upstream
even further from freedom it traveled a
short distance as crowds gathered
but then got stuck at the edge of the
river moving erratically
before losing its energy completely
hundreds watched on throughout the day
as the mammal flayed and struggled in
the currents
all wishing for a better outcome oh it's
really really sad
i did think that maybe it wasn't going
to be able to be rescued but
that's really tragic just walking across
here in people's conversations
everyone's just gutted you know they
don't like to see an animal in distress
i don't think anyone does if that's what
the alternative is the best thing for it
the rnli police and marine experts were
all here to help
even with years of experience seeing the
animal in a london lot was
extraordinary we've been doing this a
long time they are on a live monitor
this water
24 hours a day 365 days
this is the first time we've ever seen a
whale despite best efforts a vet from
london zoo was brought in to spare it
further suffering
its perilous journey brought to a bitter
end which many hoped
could have been very different ashna
harinag sky news